tiny Corp
possibly one of the greatest names of
all time for a company
uh you've launched a new company called
tiny Corp that leads the development of
tiny grad
what's the origin story of tiny Corp and
Tiny grad I started tiny grad as a like
a toy project just to teach myself okay
like what is a convolution
what are all these options you can pass
to them what is the derivative or
convolution right very similar to uh
carpathy wrote micrograd I'm very
similar
and then
I started realizing I started thinking
about like AI chips I started thinking
about chips that run
Ai and I I was like well okay this is
going to be a really big problem
if Nvidia becomes a monopoly here
um how long before Nvidia has
nationalized
so you uh
one of the reasons that start tiny Corp
is the challenge Nvidia
it's not so much to challenge Nvidia I
actually I I like Nvidia and
it's
to make sure power stays decentralized
yeah and here's uh computational Power
until you Nvidia is kind of locking down
the computational power of the world if
Nvidia becomes just like 10x better than
everything else you're giving a big
advantage to somebody who can secure
Nvidia as a resource
yeah in fact if Jensen watches this
podcast you may want to consider this
you may want to consider making sure his
company is not nationalized
do you think that's an actual threat oh
yes
no but there's so much
uh you know there's AMD so we have
Nvidia and AMD great all right
but you don't think there's like a push
towards like selling like Google selling
tpus or something like this you don't
think there's a push for that have you
seen it Google loves to rent you tpus it
doesn't you can't buy it at Best Buy
hmm so I started work on a uh
on a chip I was like okay what's it
going to take to make a chip
and my first Notions were all completely
wrong about why about like how you could
improve on gpus
uh and I will take this this is from uh
Jim Keller on your podcast uh and this
is one of my absolute favorite
descriptions of computation
um so there's three kinds of computation
paradigms that are common in the world
today
other CPUs and CPUs can do everything
CPUs can do add and multiply they can do
load and store and they can do compare
and branch and when I say they can do
these things they can do them all fast
right so compare and Branch are unique
to CPUs and what I mean by they can do
them fast is they can do things like
Branch production and speculative
execution and they spend tons of
transistors at least like super deep
reorder buffers in order to make these
things fast
then you have a simpler computation
model gpus gpus can't really do compare
and Branch I mean they can but it's
horrendously slow
but gpus can do arbitrary load in store
right gpus can do things like X
dereference Y so they can fetch from
arbitrary pieces of memory they can
fetch from memory that is defined by the
contents of the data
um the third model of computation dsps
and dsps are just add and multiply
right like they can do load in stores
but only static load in stores only
loads and stores that are known before
the program runs
good neural networks today and 95 of
neural networks are all the DSP paradigm
they are just statically scheduled ads
and multiplies
so tinyguard really took this idea and
and I'm still working on it to extend
this as far as possible
um every stage of the stack has turned
completeness right python has turned
completeness and then we take python we
go into C plus plus which is turn
complete and maybe C plus plus calls
into some Cuda kernels which are turned
complete the Cuda kernels go through lvm
which is turning complete into PTX which
is trying to complete to SAS which is
turn complete on a turn complete
processor I want to get turn
completeness out of the stack entirely
because once you get rid of turn
completeness you can reason about things
Rice's theorem and the halting problem
do not apply to Admiral machines
okay what's the power and the value of
getting torn completeness out of out of
are we talking about the hardware or the
software every layer of a stack every
layer every layer of the stack removing
current completeness allows you to
reason about things right so the reason
you need to do Branch prediction in a
CPU and the reason it's prediction and
the branch predictors are I think
they're like 99 on CPUs why did they get
one percent of them wrong well they get
one percent wrong because you can't know
right that's the halting problem it's
equivalent to the halting problem to say
whether a branch is going to be taken or
not
um I can show that but
the
admol machine the neural network runs
the identical compute every time the
only thing that changes is the data
so when you realize this you think about
okay how can we build a computer and how
can we build a stack that takes maximal
advantage of this idea
uh so what makes tiny grad different
from other neural network libraries is
it does not have a primitive operator
even for matrix multiplication
and this is every single one they even
have primitive operators things like
convolutions so no matte mull no matter
well here's what a map model is so I'll
use my hands to talk here so if you
think about a cube and I put my two
matrices that I'm multiplying on two
faces of the cube right you can think
about the Matrix multiply as okay the N
cubed I'm going to multiply for each one
in the cubed and then I'm going to do a
sum which is a reduce up to here to the
third face of the cube and that's your
multiplied Matrix
so what a matrix multiply is is a bunch
of shape operations right a bunch of
permute three shapes and expands on the
two matrices
a multiply n cubed a reduce n cubed
which gives you an N squared Matrix
okay so what what is the minimum number
of operations that can accomplish that
if you don't have uh map Mall as a
primitive so tiny grad has about 20. um
and you can compare tiny grad's uh opsat
or IR to things like xla or Prim torch
so xlan print torch are ideas we're like
okay torch has like 2 000 different
kernels
um Pi torch 2.0 introduced Prim torch
which has only 250.
tiny grad has order of magnitude 25.
it's it's 10x less than xli or Prim
torch and you can think about it as kind
of like Risk versus Sisk right these
other things are cisc like systems uh
tendergrass risk
and risk one risk architecture is going
to change everything 1995 hackers
wait really that's an actual thing
Angelina Jolie delivers the line risk
architecture is going to change
everything in 1995 and here we are with
arm and the phones
an arm everywhere wow I love it when
movies actually have real things in them
right
okay interesting and so this is like uh
so you're thinking of this as the risk
architecture of ml stack
25 huh what what uh can you can you go
through the
uh
the four op types sure
um okay so you have unaryops which take
in uh a tensor and return a tensor of
the same size and do some unary up to it
X log uh reciprocal sign right they take
in one and they're pointwise
really yeah value
um almost all activation functions are
unaryops
um some combinations of unaryops
together is still a unaryop
um then you have binary apps binary apps
are like uh Point wise Edition
multiplication division compare uh it
takes in two tensors of equal size and
outputs one tensor
then you have reduce Ops reduce Ops will
like take a three-dimensional tensor and
turn it into a two-dimensional tensor or
three-dimensional tensor turn into Zero
Dimensional tensor things like a sum or
a Max are really the common ones there
and then the four type is movement Ops
and movement Ops are different from the
other types because they don't actually
require computation they require
different ways to look at memory so that
includes reshapes permutes expands flips
those are the main ones so with that you
have enough to make a map model and
convolutions and every convolution you
can imagine dilated convolution striated
convolutions transposed convolutions
you write on GitHub about laziness
uh showing a map Mall
matrix multiplication see how despite
the style it is fused into one kernel
with the power of laziness can you
elaborate on this power of laziness sure
so if you type in pytorch a times B plus
c
uh what this is going to do is it's
going to first multiply add in B A and B
and store that result into memory and
then it is going to add C by reading
that result from memory reading C for
memory and uh writing that out to memory
there is way more loads and stores to
memory than you need there if you don't
actually do a times b as soon as you see
it if you wait
until the user actually realizes that
tensor until the laziness actually
resolves
um you can fuse that plus C this is like
it's the same way Haskell works so uh
what's the process of porting a model
into dynagrad so tiny grad's front end
looks very similar to Pi torch
um I probably could make a perfect or
pretty close to perfect interop layer if
I really wanted to I think that there's
some things that are nicer about tiny
grad syntax than pytorch but the front
end looks very torch-like you can also
load in Onyx models we have more Onyx
Test passing than core ml
okay so we'll pass Onyx run time soon
what about like the developer experience
of tiny grad
um what it feels like what are the
um
versus pytorch by the way I really like
pie torch I I think that it's actually a
very good piece of software
um I think that they've made a few
different trade-offs and these different
trade-offs are uh where you know tiny
grad takes a different path one of the
biggest differences is it's really easy
to see the kernels that are actually
being sent to the GPU
right if you run pytorch on the GPU
you like do some operation and you don't
know what kernels are in you don't know
how many kernels ran you don't know how
many flops were used you don't know how
much memory accesses were used tiny grad
type debug equals two and it will show
you in this beautiful style
um every kernel that's run
how many flops
and how many bytes
so can you just
Linger on what problem tiny grad solves
tiny grad solves the problem of porting
new ml accelerators quickly
one of the reasons or tons of these
companies now I think um
Sequoia marked graphcore to xero right
cerebus tens torrent uh grock all of
these ml accelerator companies they
built chips the chips were good the
software was terrible uh and part of the
reason is because I think the same
problems happening with dojo
it's really really hard to write a pie
torch port because you have to write 250
kernels and you have to tune them all
for performance
uh what is Jim Jim color think about
tiny grad
you guys have hung out quite a bit so
he's uh you know he's he was involved
he's involved with that story what's his
uh praise and what's his criticism of
what you're doing with your life
look
my prediction for tense torrent is that
they're gonna pivot to making risk five
tips
CPUs
why
because AI accelerators are a software
problem not really a hardware problem Oh
interesting so you don't think
you think the diversity of AI
accelerators in the hardware space is
not going to be a thing that exists long
term I think what's gonna happen is if I
can finish okay
if you're trying to make an AI
accelerator
you better have the capability of
writing a torch level performance stack
on Nvidia gpus
if you can't write a torch stack on
Nvidia gpus and I mean all the way I
mean down to the driver
there's no way you're going to be able
to write it on your chip because your
Chip's worse than a Nvidia GPU the first
version of the chip you tape out is
definitely worse when you're saying
writing that stack is really tough yes
and not only that actually the chip that
you tape out almost always because
you're trying to get advantage over
Nvidia you're specializing the hardware
more it's always harder to write
software for more specialized Hardware
like a GPU is pretty generic and if you
can't write an Nvidia stack there's no
way you can write a stack for your chip
so my Approach with tinygrad is first
write a performant Nvidia stack or
targeting AMD
um
so you did say a few to Nvidia a little
bit with love with love yeah so with the
Yankees you know I'm a Mets man oh
you're you're a mess fan a risk a risk
fan and a mess fan